I'LL JUST BE FOUND BACK. I.
OKAY SO REAL. YEAH. ALRIGHT SB.
ONE CALL. OR MEDIA. REMAINING
THERE YEAH WAS ONE. GOOD
MORNING THANK YOU FOR JOINING
ME SENATE GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE IT'S THE JUNE
THIRD MISSION AND WE WELCOME
YOU UP ARE SAFE AND WELL BEFORE
GETTING TO THIS MORNING HERE I
WOULD LIKE TO BECOME SOME
HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS AS WE TREAT
DO HERE AT THE BEGINNING.
SENATE SENATE BILL THIRTEEN
SENATOR BEATS LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN COMMITTEE SENATOR
BATES WILL BE COMING TO US LIVE
IN LOCAL FROM ORANGE COUNTY BE
WELCOMING HER IN JUST A BIT AND
WE'RE GONNA BE CONSIDERING SB.
TEEN FOR TEENS. UNDER WEEK CAN
TODAY. MAY BE GRANTED RIP
FEDERATION OF THE BILL JUST
LAST. MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
I'LL BE PRESENTING ON BEHALF OF
THE DAY SENATOR FROM A RENTED
TODAY. HIS OPINION. WE ARE
GONNA BE WELCOMING SENATOR FOR
AND AS A- THAT SENATOR BAIL
HE'LL BE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
IN THE COMMITTEE AND OF COURSE
WE WANT. TO COMMITTEE THAT
THANK YOU SOME SENATOR BELL.
THIS CAN BE THREE WAY. WITH
TODAY'S HEARING FIRST AND
FOREMOST WE'RE GONN INVITE YOU
TO BE A TO PARTICIPATE ON THE
TELEPHONE HERE'S HOW YOU
PARTICIPATE ON THE TELEPHONE IF
YOU'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO OFFER
A COMMENT THE WELCOME THAT.
TOLL FREE NUMBER EIGHT EIGHT
FOUR. WHEN SIX SIX FOUR. AND
THE YOUR IN. IS EIGHT THREE.
SIX SEVEN FOUR FIVE THAT PHONE
NUMBER INCOME IS CURRENTLY ON
YOUR SCREEN. IN ADDITION WE'RE
TAKING TESTIMONY HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE AND OF
COURSE WE'RE GOING TO BE ASKING
FOLKS TO PARTICIPATE IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY TESTIMONY IT WILL
BE. ACCEPTED AS WELL. IT IS IN
GENERAL COMMITTEE LET'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM LET'S GO TO
MR NOW MISTER NOW. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ONE HERE WATER
PRESENT SENATOR MORLOCK.
PRESIDENT BARACK PRESENT
SENATOR HERTZBERG. SENATOR AUTO
I THANK FOR CALLING PRESENT
SENATOR NICKLES PRESENT NIELSEN
PRESENT. THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
AGAIN WELCOME AT SENATOR BELL
WHO WILL BE PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY AND OF COURSE SENATOR
BAIL WE WELCOME YOUR COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE
PLEASE IT IN A COMMITTEE THAT
ENCOURAGES ME AGAIN TO IT ENDED
THE FOR ITEM IS IT SB THIRTY IN
NOW. WELCOME. CENTER BATES I
BELIEVE HE MAY BE ON MUTE WE
ARE NOT- IF YOU CAN JUST ON HIT
THE MUTE BUTTON. HER LIPS ARE
MOVING. ALL RIGHTS INNERVATES
IT'S DO A QUICK MY CHECK YOU'RE
GOOD TO GO. YOU CAN HEAR ME HEY
GOOD MORNING SENATOR BATES. WE
WELCOME YOU ON THE FLOOR IS
YOURS MA'AM. AND OUT LATELY
FIRST OF ALL- SENATOR REQUIRE
IN CHAIR HONORABLE CHAIR UP FOR
ALL COMEDY ARE THE PRESENTATION
OF THIS BILL I REALLY REALLY
APPRECIATE IT I PUT IT ON MY-
IN INDIA- LEADS TO PACKAGE
BECAUSE I BELIEVE IT'S A VERY
IMPORTANT AT LEAST HERE IN THE
DISCUSSION ON THERE. BEING THAT
IT DOES BRING REVENUES MUCH
NEEDED TO. BUDGET THIS TIME SO
LET BEGIN NOT PROBLEM. YET ARE
CLEAR CRISIS THIRTEEN NINETEEN
IT CLARIFIES THAT A CHANGE OF
CONTROL IN A CORPORATE ENTITY
OCCURS IF 90% OF THE OWNERSHIP
INTEREST IN THAT INTO TEACHING
JUST COUNTS. WITH ANY WITH ANY
THREE. EVEN IF NO ONE PERSON
GETS A MAJORITY INTEREST IN THE
LEGAL ENTITY. THIS CHANGE IN
CONTROL WOULD TRIGGER A CHANGE
OF OWNERSHIP ANDY REASSESSMENT
OF THE CORPORATIONS REAL
PROPERTY FOR PROPERTY TAX
PURPOSES CURRENTLY PROPOSITION
THIRTEEN OF NINETEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT. THERE'S A PROPERTY TAXES
NOT EXCEED THE ABILITY OF OUR
HOMEOWNER HOMEOWNERS OR
BUSINESSES ARE TO MEET OUR
GOALS TAXES HOWEVER THERE IS
YOU KNOW THE LOOPHOLE IN. THE
ADDRESS. FAMILY IS THE START
SIX PURCHASABLE WHO TO IN SAN
MONICA. WHERE THEY JUST REAL HE
STRUCTURE. THE TRANSACTION
WITHOUT ANY ONE ENTITY OWNING A
50% MAJORITY HERE ON THE
PROPERTY DESPITE THE FACT THAT
1100% OF THE OWNERSHIP OF THE
HOTEL DID CHANGE HANDS THE
PROPERTY WAS NOT RIO SOUTH STE.
SALTING AND ATTACKS FLOOR TO
OUR INITIALS COUNTY OVER A
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY. THE
THIRTEEN NINE. AND WITH STEPS
ID IN OUR OCCURS WHEN 90% OF
THE LEGAL ENTITIES OWNERSHIP
INTERESTS TRANSFERS AND A
SINGLE TRANSACTION. IN THEIR
ANALYSIS OF THIS BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION ESTIMATED THAT THE
ANNUAL REVENUE GAIN COULD
AMOUNT TO ABOUT TWO HUNDRED AND
SIXTY NINE MILLION DOLLARS.
OVER THE STATE YEAH. YOUR
SIGNIFICANT. CHANGE MEMBERS
THIRTEEN BUT SIMPLY A JOB HOW
IT IS INTERPRETED IN STATUTE A
SIMILAR BILL SB TWO FIFTY NINE
WHICH ARE ARE. FIFTEEN OUTSIDE
OF GOVERNMENT FINANCE COMMITTEE
SIX TO ZERO SO INDIANA HAVE
RELEVANCE IT STILL DOES HERE TO
TESTIFY WITH ME AS ERIC MAGGIE
FROM THE CALIFORNIA BUSINESS
ROUNDTABLE ALSO BY HERE IS
RICHARD MAN WITH THE BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION. TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS SO ALSO THE
MIKE TO ERIC AND LET HIM ON OUR-
PROVIDE THE ABOUT ON THE BILL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MADAM SENATOR
WE APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN COMMITTEE
WE'RE NOT GONNA BE GOING TO OUR
LEAD WITNESS ON BEHALF OF SB
THIRTEEN NINETEEN THAT'S ERIC
MAGGIE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS ROUNDTABLE MISTER
DICKEY YOU HAVE. THREE MINUTES
WE ALSO AND THAT WILL BE HERE
FROM DAVID WOLF TODAY FROM THE
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION MISTER MACKEY THE
FLOOR IS YOURS YOUR NOW LIVE IN
COMMITTEE GOOD MORNING SIR.
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MEMBERS I AM MERRICK
MICKEY CAPITAL LONG POLICY
REPRESENTING THE BUSINESS
ROUNDTABLE IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTEEN NINETEEN SB THIRTEEN
NINETEEN IS A WELL THOUGHT OUT
AND CAREFULLY BALANCED MEASURE
TO ADDRESS A TAX PLANNING
OPPORTUNITY THAT IS TURNED INTO
A SHOW FOR USE. UNDER PROP
THIRTEEN. PROPERTIES ON BEST
UPON THE CHANGE OF OWNERSHIP
AND UNDER CALIFORNIA LAW
CORPORATIONS HAVE THEIR OWN
SEPARATE LEGAL IDENTITIES FROM
THEIR SHAREHOLDERS. TAKEN OWN
PROPERTY IN THEIR OWN NAME.
FIRSTLY THE AVERAGE SHAREHOLDER
BUT NO RIGHT TO POSSESS ARE
OCCUPIED CORPORATE PROPERTY SO
TAKEN AT FACE VALUE PROP
THIRTEEN- REASSESS HIS
CORPORATE OWNED PROPERTY ONLY
WHEN THE CORPORATION SOLD THAT
PROPERTY TO UPON RELATE. PERSON
OR ENTITY AND WHEN THE OWNER
BEEN TRIP THAT CORPORATION TRY.
AND INDEED THAT WAS THE
RECOMMENDATION THE TASK FORCE
ON PARK PROPERTY TAX
ADMINISTRATION THAT FORMED
UNDER THE AUSPICES OF THE
ASSEMBLY REVAN TAX COMMITTEE
AFTER PROP THIRTEEN PARA WAY
BACK IN NINETEEN TO DATE. NO
LEGISLATURE ADOPTED LAMENTING
LET QUESTION THOUGH THEY'D BE
DEVIATED SLIGHTLY FROM THE
SEPARATE INTO THE
RECOMMENDATION OF THE TASK
FORCE AND THEY EMBRACED THE
STRUCTURE WE HAVE TODAY THE
THAT THE- MISSION. HEY MORE
THAN 2% BRANDY THE USE THE TERM
ULTIMATE CONTROL OF THE ENTITY
IS BEING TRANSFERRED AND SEEING
AND SINCE THAT NEW MAJORITY
INTEREST HOLDER COULD THEN
DETERMINE THE DISPOSITION
CORPORATE PROPERTY. IT'S ALSO
DEEMED TO BE A QUOTE CHANGE OF
OWNERSHIP OF THAT CORPORATE
PROPERTY. NOW THIS IS A FICTION
IT'S A LIMITED FICTION THAT
ACTUALLY IS AT ODDS WITH PROPER
TEENS WORDING. BUT IT WAS
ADOPTED BY THE LEGISLATURE WITH
THE BEST OF INTENTIONS THEY
WERE TRYING TO ENSURE PEACE.
BETWEEN THE RELATIVE TAX.
BUSINESS AND RESIDENTIAL
PROPERTIES. YOU KNOW IN TIME
THOUGH SHARP TAX PLANNERS
REALIZE THAT THEY COULD
TRANSFER THE CORPORATE INTEREST
IN THIS. ANY THERE TO THERE IS
A RELATED AND THE- AND IF THEY
KEPT ALL THE ENTITIES OWNERSHIP
INTEREST 50% THAT THEY CAN
SIMPLY SELL UP PRETTY. WELL OUT
CAUSING OWNERSHIP IN
REASSESSMENT OF THAT PROPERTY
AND THAT PLANNING OPPORTUNITY
SIMPLY BECAME AN ALL TOO
TEMPTING POTENTIAL FOR ABUSE
THE STAKES WERE HIGH KNOW. IT
RED. THE ANSWER. TO ONE AND
THAT PROP. SB TO. REASON I'M
WELL MY APPROACH TO WOULD ONLY
THIS FOR ABUSE AND CLARA REYES
MUCH NEEDED READ FOR SO AND
WILL GOVERNMENT AND THE TABLE
ENDORSES SB THIRTEEN NIGHT AND
SENATOR BATES SPONSORS AND
AGAIN I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE MAY
HAVE- THANK VERY MUCH. NAME IS
MICKEY THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY LADIES IN GERMAN
WE'RE NOT GONNA BE MOVING TO
SUPPORT PORTION OF TODAY'S
HEARING FOR IS THIRTEEN
NINETEEN. IT'S GO TO. MODERATOR
MADAME MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANY
INDIVIDUALS WHO WOULD LIKE TO
BE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT IN
SUPPORT. OF SB THIRTEEN
NINETEEN MATTER MODERATOR. IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB THIRTEEN NINETEEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE THAN THEIR OWN
NOW. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTEEN NINETEEN PRESS ONE
THAN THEIR OWN NOW. IN ONE
MOMENT TO DETERMINE THANKS SO
MUCH AMANDA MODERATOR FOLKS WHO
WANT TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT AT
THIS BILL OR AND NOW IT'S
THIRTEEN FORTY NINE THE TOLL
FREE NUMBER IS. EIGHT FOUR FOUR
NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR
THAT WOULD BE A SEVEN EIGHT
THREE. SIX SEVEN FOUR FIVE
PHONE NUMBER IS CURRENTLY
SCREEN DURING THE FORTY HEARING
FOR ME MADAME MODERATOR. TO
PLEASE. THANK YOU LAW NUMBER
SEVENTEEN THE OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD GOOD MORNING. NINE YEAH
MISTER MISTER CHAIRMAN HE HEAR
ME A GOOD MORNING MISTER WOLF
WE WELCOME YOU THE FLOOR IS
YOURS SIR YOUR LIGHTING
COMMITTEE. WONDERFUL THANK YOU
SIR HEY DAVID WHAT'S TODAY
ACTUALLY WITH MY OWN COMPANY
WALBRIDGE CONSULTING
INCORPORATED ON BEHALF OF THE
HOWARD JARVIS TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION. I WOULD LIKE TO
SAY MY COMMENTS OF COURSE
ALIGNED WITH MISTER MACKEY AND
I'M VERY THANKFUL GRAHAM-
PRESENTING MISSPELLED PROVIDING
SUPPORT- I'M- IT SHOULD HAVE
ALWAYS. AND THE INDIVIDUAL IF
SHOULD PAY PROPERTY TAXES BUT-LEGITIMATELY OUT ALLIES BEING
ABUSED IN SUCH A WAY THAT LEADS
TO UNFAIR TA POLICY IT SHOULD
BE CORRECTED. THIRTEEN NINETY
SURE IS THAT AGREE JUST
EXAMPLES LIKE THE HOTEL
PURCHASE SENATOR BATES
REFERENCED SHOULD AND WILL BE
SAID THREE ASSESSMENT I'D ALSO
LIKE TO SAY JUST THINK. WILL
GENERATE ADDITIONAL ROLE BERMAN.
FORMER HIGHER PROPERTY TAX.
IMPORTANT IN THIS TIME OF
COVERAGE NINE AT THAT ABOUT
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER PUT
HIS OWN MISTER. YEAH
CONGRATULATIONS THIS OFF THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THE TESTIMONY
WE'RE STILL IN OUR SUPPORT MODE
MADAM DO WE ANYONE IN IN SO OF
IT T. THIRTEEN NINETEEN ON THE
LINE. I'M THE TERM AND WE DO
NOT. THE LAST CALL FOR SUPPORT
ON SB THIRTEEN NINETEEN PLEASE.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SUPPORT SB ONE THREE ONE NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO NOW. THIS
IS LAST CALL FOR SB THIRTEEN
NINETEEN LAST CALL FOR SUPPORT
SB THIRTEEN NINETEEN MATTER
MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE LINE.
NO SIR CHAIRMAN THERE IS NO ONE
ELSE THANK YOU MADAM MODERATOR
LADIES AND JENNA COMMITTEE
WE'RE NOT GONNA BE TURNING IN
HERE TO FORTY THREE TO BE TO
SEE IF WE HAVE ANYONE IN
SUPPORT PLEASE STEP UP. THE
SCENE NO ONE WE'RE GOING TO
ROUTE TWENTY FORTY ROOM TWENTY
FORTY THERE IS NO ONE ROOM
TWENTY FORTY LADIES AND GENTS
MANY WERE GONNA BE GOING TO
THE- MAY BE OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL OVER MOVING INTO
OPPOSITION. WE CAN AT LEAST.
RECORD HERE. HER NAME IS CORBIN
KEYS WITH THE CALIFORNIA TAX
REFORM ASSOCIATION SHE'S GONNA
BE JOINING US ON THE PHONE THAT
LAYS IN GENERAL COMMITTEE
THAT'S WELCOME IS COPING IN THE
CALIFORNIA TAX REFORM
ASSOCIATION LEAD WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION MISS CORBIN WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU'RE ON THE
LINE. THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
YOU HAVE THREE MINUTES THE
FLOOR IS YOURS YOU'RE NOW LIVE
IN COMMITTEE. GOOD MR CARE
MEMBERS MEDICAL BEEN WITH A
CALIFORNIA TAX REFORM
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION. THE
THIRTEEN NINETEEN. WELL THE
CURRENT SYSTEM IS BROKEN IT
DOES NOT SOLVE THE PROBLEM THE
NEW STANDARDS THAT BY THE
MEASURE HAS NO JUSTIFICATION OR
POLICY RATIONALE. THE TECH
CHAIR ON THE- ACCORDINGLY IT
WOULD BE STILL QUITE SIMPLE TO
SET UP A DEAL UNDER THE TERMS
OF THE BELL TO AVOID
REASSESSMENT. THEREFORE WE CAN
EXPECT COMPANIES WILL CONTINUE
TO USE COMPLEX LEGAL MANEUVERS
TO AVOID REASSESSMENT UNDER THE
NEW 90% THRESHOLD PUBLISHED IN
THE WELL. EXAMPLES LIKE THOSE
MENTIONED IN THE ANALYSIS AS
WELL AS BY THE AUTHOR WILL
CONTINUE TO OCCUR. I EXPLICITLY
EXEMPTING THE TRANSFEROF STOCK
OR OWNERSHIP SHARES SB THIRTEEN
NINETEEN. THE COURT WORST BY.
THAT CORPORATION MOST REAL
ESTATE INVESTMENT TRUST AND I
WILL YOU ARE EXEMPT FROM
CHANGING OVER OWNERSHIP. CHANGE
OF OWNERSHIP IS EASILY AVOIDED
BY CORPORATIONS AND WEALTHY
INVESTORS BECAUSE OF THE
COMPLEX WAYS COMMERCIAL AND
INDUSTRIAL PROPERTIES ARE
LEGALLY HOW. WE TRADED
CORPORATION TO STOCKS OVER
REGULARLY CHANGE OF OWNERSHIP
TO TRIGGER MEANT A LOT THAT
COMPANIES ARE HIGHER WE BOUGHT
OUT. SB THIRTEEN ALSO DOES NOT
ADDRESS THE INEQUITY AND
FUNDAMENTAL PROBLEM OF THE LONG
HELD PROPERTIES THAT ARE STILL
PAYING I WOULD BE DEAD AND
UNFAIR TAX IS BASED ON PROPERTY
VALUES. SEVENTY EIGHTY. WELL
THE MEASURE MAY PRODUCE A
COUPLE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
REVENUE FOR THE STATE.
CALIFORNIA WOULD IN FACT MOVE
BILLION. WE NEED OF REVENUE FOR
SCHOOLS AND LOCAL SERVICE AND
BY NOT WE AFFECTING COMMERCIAL
AND INDUSTRY PROPERTY
DEATHSTROKE. MARKET VALUE.
FURTHERMORE THE CURRENT SYSTEM
IF THE UNFAIR TO START UP A
NEWER BUSINESS THAT THAT PAIN
MILLIONS MORE IN PROPERTY TAX
FOR THE LAND DOWN NOT ONLY DOES
THIS PROPOSAL NOT GO FAR ENOUGH
IT WILL BE AN IMPEDIMENT
EFFORTS FROM OLDER STRUCTURAL
REFORM. IN FACT THERE IS
ANOTHER OPTION CURRENTLY ON THE
BALLOT THE SCHOOL COMPLETELY
BALLOT MEASURE WHICH SEEKS TO
ADDRESS THE FUNDAMENTAL
QUADCOPTER. COMMERCIAL PROPERTY
TAX THE CALL. PERSON
LEGISLATURE TO FOCUS ON WILL
SOLUTION LIKE COMPREHENSIVE
REFORM THAT WILL RAISE THE
WEDDING AND WE NEED FIFTY FIFTY
FOUR BILLION DOLLARS. FOR THOSE
URGED COMMITTEE NOW I'M AT
THIRTEENTH NINETEEN. WITH THANK
YOU SO MUCH WE SHOULD MORNING A
CREATE YOUR TO. IN OFFICE. OF
S. THIRTY. NINETY LADY AND JACK
WHERE GOING TO BE TURNING THIS
OVER TO OUR MODERATOR THE
MODERATOR IS GOING TO BE
ENOUGH. IN THE JUNE TWO MAY BE
IN OPPOSITE OF SP THIRTEEN
NINETEEN MATTER MODERATOR CAN
YOU PLEASE PUT FOLKS IN THE
QUEUE. WAITED UNTIL. IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITE. OF SB THIRTEEN
NINETEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE THAN
THEIR OWN NOW. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THIRTEEN
NINETEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE THAN
THEIR OWN NOW. THANK YOU MAY.
MEN THANK YOU SO MUCH VENOM
MODERATOR APPRECIATE YOUR WORK
TODAY IN THE INDIVIDUAL WE KEEP
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE DIAL EIGHT FOUR FOUR.
TWO SIX THREE SIX FOUR. SEVEN
EIGHT THREE SIX SEVEN FOUR FIVE
IF YOU NEED ANY PROBLEMS THAT
NUMBER IS ON SCREEN. BELMONT
WE'RE GONNA BE COMING BACK TO
SEE IF WE HAVE ANYONE IN THE
QUEUE IN OPPOSITION SB
THIRTEEN. MADAME MODERATOR. WE
DO HAVE SOMEONE MORE MOMENTS
DETERMINE THEY'RE GIVING THEIR
NUMBER NOW THANK YOU SO MUCH
MA'AM. YOU'RE WELCOME ONE
MOMENT. A LINE TWENTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD MORNING- I'M CALLING TO
OPPOSE. EIGHTY EIGHT ZERO MA'AM
HI MY NAME IS SANDRA ALLEN I
MEAN I AM A TALE COUNTY CANDOR
I APOLOGIZE. AT CENTER I DO
APOLOGIZE WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO
IT'S GOING TO HOLD ON FOR ONE
MOMENT. BECAUSE WORD TAKING
TESTIMONY RIGHT NOW ON SB
THIRTEEN NINETEEN WHAT WE'RE
GONNA DO SANDRA AND I APOLOGIZE
WE'RE GOING TO BE UP. HERE IN
JUST A MOMENT- AND WE'LL GET
YEAH CONNECTED TO THE RIGHT
ALSO THANK YOU SO MUCH MA'AM
PLEASE HOLD ON FOR MOMENT IN
TERM IN. WORK AT I ON YOUR TEST.
MADAM MODERATOR WE'RE NOW GOING
TO BE LOOKING TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE ELSE ON SB THIRTEEN
NINETEEN WE'RE LOOKING FOR
ANYONE ELSE ON SB THIRTY.
NINETEEN IN OPPOSITION META
MODERATED WITH ANYONE IN THE
QUEUE. SOMEONE ELSE'S AND NOW
MR I MEAN ONE MOMENT SIR THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THE SHOOTER WAS
PATIENTS HERE TODAY. AND MY
NUMBER TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN FOR SB THIRTEEN NINETEEN
IN OPPOSITION GOOD MORNING I
PLEASE IF THERE CHAIRMAN- THIS
IS DAVID SHOWN BROWN CALLING
FROM YOUR- YOUR DISTRICT- IN
THE HEARING THE TESTIMONY- ON
THIS BILL- I WAS SURPRISED HE
HERE THE BUSINESS ROUNDTABLE
SPEAKING IN SOME IN FAVOR OF A
BILL THAT WOULD INCREASE TAXES.
I'M IN HERE FACT REFORM ASSOC.
IT BECAME APPARENT THAT THIS
BILL IS INTENDED TO DEFLECT-
THE- AFFECT OF A SPLIT ROLE-
INITIATIVE- AND THAT IT IS IN
EFFECT- ATTEMPTING TO DISTRACT
VOTERS AWAY FROM THE PRIZE
WHICH IS THE- SPLIT ROLE AND-
THAT BASIS- I URGE YOU. TO
OPPOSE THE BILL THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU SO
MUCH WE APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY AND GOOD MORNING TO
YOU SIR WE'RE GRATEFUL THAT YOU
HAVE JOINED ON THE LINE WE'RE
NOW GOING TO. THE MARCH. WE
HAVE AN OUNCE THANK YOU IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THIRTEEN
NINETEEN MATTER MODERATOR. AT
THIS MOMENT EXAMINE WE DO NOT
HAVE ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU MADAM MODERATOR WE'RE
GONNA DO A LAST CALL LAST CALL
FOR SB THIRTEEN NINETEEN
OPPOSITION TO TURN IT OVER TO
YOU MADAME MODERATOR. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THIRTEEN
NINETEEN CONFRONTS ONE DIDN'T
ZERO. THAT'S ONE ZERO TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB THIRTEEN
NINETEEN. THE TERM AND WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE IN Q. AND A
MODERATOR GREAT JOB THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR ASKING ME BRING IN
IN TO HEAR ROOM FORTY TWO OR
THREE TO SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO BE
UNDERSTANDING SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THANKSGIVING IN OPPOSITION
OF SB THIRTEEN NINETEEN.
NINETEEN NO ONE STAND IN
OPPOSITION WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO
BE A TO GO TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY
ROOM TWENTY FORTY TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. NADA SO
WE'RE GONNA BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE TODAY TO SEE IF WE
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS
AND AGAIN I WANT TO. APOLOGIZE
TO SANDRA WHO CALLED MANAGER
BILL AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
HEARING YOUR TESTIMONY BUT
LATER. WE'D LIKE TO GO TO SEE
IF WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS COME
WERE AND TURNED OVER TO THE
VICE CHAIR. RICE AND WE'RE
GONNA. OVER THE DEAN AND SENATE
LAST YEAR. Q. STRUCTURE I'M-
JUST MAYBE REAR. TOURIST TO
SOME OF THE COMMON THAT HAVE
BEEN. MISTER CHAIR. IS IT. SAYS
THE- NEEDS. CURRENT FUNDING
WHICH- SEEMS LIKE AN- REASON TO
OPPOSE OF ONE WE'VE- GET THIS.
BILL PAY. IN A MAN. TO STRING.
IT BUT THIS IS A BILL THAT. HAS
BEEN ATTEMPTED FOR A LONG TIME.
SO SOMEONE SAYING THAT IT WAS A
DISTRACTION FOR SPLIT ROLE
SEEMS. HISTORICALLY INACCURATE-
THIS IS BEEN ATTEMPTED BY
SENATOR BATES. ON A NUMBER OF
OCCASIONS- ALONG WITH. I
BELIEVE SPLIT ROLE WAS
INTRODUCED AS A- TECHNIQUE TO
RAISE. POST A PROPER TAXES SO-
I WILL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
TODAY RESEARCHER. I'M ALSO
CURIOUS IF THERE ARE AMENDMENTS
THAT- IF THE AUTHOR WOULD LIKE
ANOTHER CO AUTHOR I'M HAPPY TO
DO SO. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS A VICE
CHAIR THE VICE YEARS OFFERING
HIMSELF UP AND TO BE A CO
AUTHOR VERY VERY GRATEFUL SIR
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORDS ARE
NOT GOING TO TURN IT OVER TO
SENATOR NIELSEN. NIELSEN THANK
YOU MISSION THEN I TO LOW ECHO
MY SUPPORT FOR THE MEASURE. AND
I WILL NOTE THAT THE SO CALLED
SPLIT ROLE OR TREATING BUSINESS
A CALL TO HOMEOWNERS. WAS NOT A
FULL IT WAS INTENDED FOR EQUITY
PARITY THAT A CRUCIAL TIME. AND
EVERY. EVERY YEAR SAID FROM
THIRTEEN. THERE HAVE BEEN
ATTEMPTS TO SPLIT THE ROLE HERE
YET AGAIN. THIS PARTICULAR
MEASURE DOES NOT DO HARM TO
THAT AT ALL IT'S A KIND OF I
DON'T RECALL TO CLEAN UP. BUT
THE POINT IS WE CANNOT
CHARACTERIZE PROP THIRTEEN IS
SOME DISASTER WE'VE DONE VERY
WELL SENSE AND THE THOUSANDS
AND THOUSANDS OF HOMEOWNERS.
HAVE BENEFITTED AND BUSINESSES
AND THERE'S NO REASON WHY
BUSINESS SHOULD NOT EQUITABLY
BE CONSIDERED THIS IS NOT A
LOOPHOLE WAS FULLY ATTENDED.
YOU SO MUCH MISTER SENATOR
PLEASE GOING TO GO TO CENTER
WIENER SAN WIENER THE MONEY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN-
HIGH- WHAT I WILL NOT BE ABLE
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY- I
DO APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD- BUT IT
IS- TOO NARROW TO ME IT DOESN'T
SOLVE THE PROBLEM. AND WHETHER
IT WAS A LOOPHOLE OR INTENDED
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT YOU
KNOW I WILL SAY THAT I WAS NOT
LIVING IN CALIFORNIA IN
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT. EIGHT
YEARS OLD AT THE TIME- SO I AM
NOT SPEAKING FROM PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE HERE- BUT I WILL SAY
THAT. YOU KNOW MY SENSE IS THAT
WHEN PEOPLE ARE VOTING ON PROP
THIRTEEN THE FOCUS WAS ON.
PEOPLE BEING POTENTIALLY PUSH
UP THEIR HOMES BY HAVING THEIR
PROPERTY TAXES INCREASE
PARTICULARLY PEOPLE OF MODEST
MEANS ARE ON FIXED INCOMES I
DON'T KNOW THAT PEOPLE ARE NUTS
VOTING ON WHETHER THE-
TRANSAMERICA PYRAMID IN BANK OF
AMERICA- BUILDING. IN SEVENTY
WOULD RECEIVE THIS OR FRANKLY
MORE PROP THIRTEEN- TREATMENT
THAN PEOPLE'S HOMES AND SO HAS
REGARDLESS OF WHAT WAS INTENDED
OR WHETHER OR NOT IT WAS A
LOOPHOLE- RIGHT THE REALITY IS
THAT WE HAVE A VERY INEQUITABLE
SYSTEM NOW- AND WE HAVE. THE
ABILITY OF- PARTICULARLY LARGER
COMMERCIAL. LANDOWNERS TO
STRUCTURE TRANSACTIONS IN WAYS
THAT HOMEOWNERS CAN'T. WRITE
HOMEOWNERS IT'S NOT REALLY
POSSIBLE TO STRUCTURE
TRANSACTIONS IN A WAY THAT
AVOIDS PROP THIRTEEN RECESS ON-
AND THAT'S ABOUT. VERY IT'S NOT
A RESULT THEY WERE GIVING NOT
JUST. THE SAME BUT EVEN MORE
PROTECTION THE COMMERCIAL
PROPERTIES- THE OTHER PIECE OF
IT THERE'S A HUGE INEQUITY
AMONG. A BUSINESSES AND AGAIN
KEEPING IN SAN FRANCISCO IT'S
WHAT I KNOW BEST THAT YOU KNOW
YOU HAVE THE SALES FORCE TOWER
YOUR BANK OF AMERICA BUILDING-
THAT'S- I DON'T HAVE THOSE
NUMBERS BUT- YOU KNOW ICE
THAT'S THAT'S NOT FAIR. JUST IN
TERMS OF A MOM BUSINESSES-
HAVING TO HAVING THAT KIND OF
IN EQUITY AND THEN ON TOP OF
ALL THAT EXIST PHILOSOPHICALLY.
SHOULD LARGE COMMERCIAL
BUILDINGS RECEIVE PROP THIRTEEN
PROTECTION AGAIN THE ANSWER IS
NO- AND I THINK WE SHOULD
STRUCTURALLY ALL THAT- THIS
DOESN'T GO FAR ENOUGH- AND SO I
WILL NOT BE SUPPORTING IT TODAY
WITH ALL RESPECT TO- OF THE
AUTHOR WHO I KNOW IS COMING AT
THIS FROM A GOOD PLACE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH AS
CENTER WINNER WERE VERY
GRATEFUL APPRECIATE THOSE WORDS
NOT LIKE TO BE A TO SEE I HAVE
A FEW WORDS BEFORE WE TURN OVER
TO SENATOR BATES BUT WOULD LIKE
TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY
ADDITIONAL CONVERSATION. FROM
THE COMMITTEE AT THIS TIME.
MISTER VICE CHAIR WOULD YOU
LIKE TO BE TO MAKE A MOTION.
HAPPY TO MAKE THE MOST TAXED BY
SHARES MADE A MOTION THIS IS A
DO PASTOR APPROPRIATIONS- IT'S
JUST A FEW CLOSING WORDS AND-
AGAIN WILL TURN IT OVER TO.
SENATOR BATES AT FIRST AND
FOREMOST PROPOSITION THIRTEEN
WILL BE. FIVE YEARS OLD. I KNOW
THAT. REMAINS ONE OF CONTRA.
ISSUES IN CALIFORNIA TAX POLICY
OR AT THE VERY LEAST ONE THE
MOST TALKED ABOUT. IN SUPPORT
OR NOT TO BEGIN SUPPORTER NOT
THIS NOVEMBER. VOTERS WILL HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO
ACT ON THE QUESTION. ABOUT THE
ASSESSMENT OF COMMERCIAL AND
INDUSTRIAL PROPERTY. THIS BILL-
PRIOR TO THE NOVEMBER BALLOT
THAT TAKES A PIECEMEAL APPROACH
TO THIS COMPLICATED IN
IMPORTANT CHALLENGE. A AND THIS
IS NO SLIGHT ON THIS AUTHOR-
THIS AUTHOR AT SENATOR BATES
HAS BEEN INCREDIBLY HARD
WORKING. SHE'S BEEN COMMITTED
TO THIS ISSUE AND HAS TAKEN
TIME TAKEN TIME TO BE A TO
DEVELOP THE POLICY. AND MY
BELIEF IS THAT WE SHOULD LET
VOTERS DO THEIR THING IN
NOVEMBER. IF FOR SOME REASON
THIS INITIATIVE FAILS. OR IF
THIS IS AN ON THE BALLOT AT BE
VERY HAPPY TO BE A TO
RECONSIDER. THIS BILL IN FRONT
OF COMMITTEE AGAIN I WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU TO SENATOR BATES
FOR ALL OF HER EFFORT THAT
THERE ARE NO AMENDMENTS IN
FRONT OF THE COMMITTEE TO DATE.
THE CHAIR WILL BE VOTING NO.
AND WILL TURN IT OVER TO
SENATOR BATES FOR CLOSING COMES.
WILL LET'S SEE A LIGHT HEALTH
YOU HEAR ME I'M NOT YES THANK
YOU FIRST AND FOREMOST A-
SENATE-ROOM ACQUIRING AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I REALLY
REALLY APPRECIATE. THE ROBUST
DISCUSSION ON SB THIRTEEN
NINETY NINE. PROBABLY BETTER
SAY I DO THERE IS AN AMBIGUITY
OUR THERE'S- PLANNING
OPPORTUNITY THAT CURRENTLY
EXISTS. OUR PRODUCT- IN THE-
USE. PROP THIRTEEN SO. THIS
REALLY IS INTENDED TO ASSIST
IMMEDIATELY ARE WITHOUT PROPER
COLLECTION OF TAXES THAT ARE
DUE WHEN OUR COMMERCIAL
PROPERTY TRANSFERS OWNERSHIP.
OUR STATE IS IN A VERY VERY
SIGNIFICANT OUR- SITUATION ARE
THE DIFFERENT SAID YEARS ON
BEYOND COMPREHENSION- THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT CAN HAPPEN VERY
QUICKLY AND I THINK IT BRINGS
VERNELL SWITCHES BàN OUR TOPIC
OF DISCUSSION ON THIS FOR MANY
YEARS YOU KNOW THAT ATTEMPTS TO
FIX. THEIR FILE ON THEM YOU
GIVE IT TO YOU IN THIS PLANNING
OPPORTUNITY HAS GONE ON FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS I THINK THE
FIRST BILL INTRODUCED WAS BACK
IN. NINETEEN NINETY ONE
NINETEEN NINETY SOMETHING LIKE
THAT. SO PLEASE LET ME CORRECT
EIGHTY HIGH. THAT THIS AN
CAMPUS YOU YOUR RENT OR- OUR
THE NO THEY BALLOT ISSUE OF
THAT PASSED IT TAKES. TO SEASON
STARTS. SO APPROVING AND HAS
NOTHING TO DO OUR HOUSE I TRY.
ARE THE THIRTEEN ISSUED WILL BE
A THE BALLOT. AND IT WILL BE
I'M CERTAIN ON. TOM FOR MANY
WEEKS BEFORE THAT LOTUS TAKE
AND ANDERSON OPPORTUNITY IF IT
DOES FAIL THIS WILL BE THERE
ARE IMMEDIATELY TO BRING US.
WHAT TWO HUNDRED ALMOST SEVENTY
MILLION DOLLARS WITH THE NEXT
HALF CYCLE SO I URGE YOUR
SUPPORT AYE HE- ANNOUNCES NOT
THERE BUT CHAU IT WAS A VERY
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION. IT'S A
VERY IMPORTANT CONVERSATION TO
CONTINUE ALL RIGHT ON THROUGH
OUR BUDGET DISCUSSIONS THE
BETTER JUST AROUND THE CORNER
SO AGAIN THANK YOU AND I DO ASK
FOR YOUR IDOL. THANK YOU SO
MUCH CENTER BATES- VERY
GRATEFUL FOR THE ELOQUENT
TESTIMONY- IN YOUR PRESENTATION
HERE TODAY LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
COMMITTEE WE DO HAVE A MOTION
ON THE FLOOR THE MOTION THE
FLOORS BYE BYE STIR MORE
LOCKED. THAT MOTION IS A TOOTH
PASTOR APPROPRIATIONS. MR NOW
CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR MCGUIRE NO WATER NO
SENATOR MORLOCK LIKE OR LOCK HI
SENATOR HERTZBERG. SENATOR TADO
NOW FOR TARA NO SENATOR
NIELSEN. NIELSEN ARE SENATOR
WIENER. WIENER NO. IF TWO TO
THREE THANK YOU SO MUCH THAT
VOTE IS CURRENTLY TWO TO THREE
TWO TO THREE SENATOR BELL WILL
NOT BE VOTING AS HE IS REMOTE
HERE TODAY SO THE MEASURE FAILS
THE MEASURE FAILS ON ON A TWO
TO THREE VOTE LACING GENTLEMEN
OF COMMITTEE. WE'RE GONNA TAKE
A QUICK RECESS GIVE US FIVE
MINUTES WE'RE GONNA TAKE A
QUICK RECESS FIVE MINUTE RECESS
AND WE'LL COME BACK IN FIVE
MINUTES.
KICK STARTED HERE IN
ABOUT THIRTY SECONDS. IN THIS
THIRTY SECONDS I'D LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO DO A MIKE CHECK MY
CHECK FOR THE MODERATOR AT
MADAME MODERATOR. WE COMING
THROUGH LOUD AND CLEAR. YES ARE
COMING TO A VERY CLEAR. THANK
YOU MADAM MODERATOR WILL BE
STARTING IN THIRTY SECONDS.
WELCOME BACK LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN WELCOME BACK TO THE
SENDING GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO GO BACK TO ITEM NUMBER ONE-
WONDERING IF THERE'S UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO GRANT
RECONSIDERATION ON ITEM ONE SP
THIRTEEN NINETEEN. HEARING SEEN
ALL. YES THERE IS-
RECONSIDERATION GRANTED ON SB
THIRTEEN NINETEEN
RECONSIDERATION GRANTED ON SB.
THIRTEEN NINETEEN. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN WE ARE NOW GOING TO
BE MOVING TO ITEM NUMBER TWO
THIS IS OUR FINAL ITEM ON
TODAY'S AGENDA THIS IS SB
THIRTEEN FORTY NINE SENATOR
GLAZER SENATOR GLAZER WILL NOT
BE WITH THIS TODAY I WILL BE
PRESENTING ON BEHALF OF CENTER
GLAZER THIS IS. UNDER
RECONSIDERATION MEMBERS- SB
THIRTEEN FORTY NINE IS AN
IMPORTANT BILL FOR SENATOR
GLAZERS DISTRICT EIGHT IF YOU
REMEMBER PERMITS CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY IN CITIES WITHIN CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY ADDITIONAL LEGAL
FLEXIBILITY TO ASK FOR VOTERS
TO APPROVE LOCAL TAXES THE
COUNTY UNIT CITIES ARE
CURRENTLY RESTRICTED FROM DOING
SO BECAUSE OF THE TWO PERCENT.
COUNTY WIDE CALF IN STATE LAW
THIS BILL AS I'MSURE EACH AND
EVERYONE REMEMBERS IS VERY
SIMILAR TO AB SEVEN TWENTY
THREE WHICH LEGISLATURE
APPROVED IN THE GOVERNOR SIGNED
LAST YEAR THAT WAS A BILL DONE
BY MR QUIRK. THAT WE TOOK FULL
TESTIMONY ON THIS MEASURE TWO
WEEKS AGO WHERE THE COMMITTEE
HEARD FROM BOTH COUNTERPARTS
COUNTY SUPERVISOR JOHN JOYA AND
THE MAYOR OF CONCORD TEN
BATTALION IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL WE WERE ALSO GRATEFUL THAT
MISTER WOLF ARE REPRESENTING
THE HOWARD JARVIS TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION- TESTIFIED IN
OPPOSITION. AS YOU ALL KNOW
AFTER TESTIMONY THE BILL WENT
ON CALL WITH THREE EYES AND TWO
NO'S BUT THE COMMITTEE
ADJOURNED AGAIN THIS IS WHERE
WE MISS MISS LANCHESTER AND WE
ARE WELL BY THE WAY BUT THE
COMMITTEE ADJOURNED WITHOUT
LIFTING THE CALL WHICH MEANT
THAT FAILED WITHOUT AND GRANTED
RECONSIDERING. SO LAST WEEK YOU
ALL THANK YOU SO MUCH- IN FOR
YOUR GENEROUS SUPPORT OF THIS
LAST WEEK THE COMMITTEE GRANTED
RECONSIDERATION ON THE ITEM SO
IT IS NOW BACK BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE FOR FULL
CONSIDERATION WERE GONNA BE
ASKING. FOR YOUR HI OR NO VOTE
HERE TO DAY WHAT WE'D LIKE TO
BETTER DO BEFORE THOUGH IS THAT
WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO GO TO
OUR PHONE LINES ARE GONNA GO TO
OUR PHONE LINES FIRST AND WE'RE
GONNA SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO BE A TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. WE'RE
GOING TO ASK THE MODERATOR.
WE'RE GONNA ASK THE MODERATOR
TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY IN SO. OF
SB THIRTY FORTY. IN SUPPORT OF
SB THIRTEEN FORTY NINE. BETTER
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE Q.
WHAT FOLKS WHO WOULD LIKE TO BE
A TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTEEN FORTY NINE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTEEN FORTY NINE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE DIDN'T ZERO. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB ONE
THREE FOUR NINE. PLEASE PRESS
ONE DIDN'T ZERO NOW. AS THE
MODERATOR. DETERMINE THANK YOU
SO MUCH AS A MODERATOR IS
GIVING FOLKS UP ORGAN AND
ENCOURAGE YOU TO CALL US AT
844-291-6364 YOU CAN ALSO GET
THAT CODE TO COME TALK TO US.
SEVEN EIGHT THREE SIX SEVEN
FOUR FIVE WE LOOK FORWARD TO
HEARING FROM YOU HERE IN JUST A
BIT. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
COMMITTEE WHAT WE GO TO A
MODERATOR TO SEE IF WE HAVE
ANYONE IN THE QUEUE IN SUPPORT
OF SB THIRTEEN FORTY NINE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN. LINE
NUMBER NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD
MORNING. GOOD MORNING GERMANY
AND MEMBERS ARE MARC WATTS ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTRY COSTA
COUNTY TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY
WE ARE IN FAVOR OF THIS
MEASURE- WE HAVE SEEN WITHIN
THE COUNTY IS THAT TRANSACTION
USE TAX. AS AN IMPORTANT TOOL
FOR CITIES COUNTY AND IN OUR
INSTANT WELL WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
USE HEALTH TAX DATA PROVED
TWICE BY THE VOTERS. TO DO SUCH
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS LIKE THE PORT FOR THE
COLOR CUT TUNNEL HIGHLIGHTING I
OR IN PART EXTENSION OF THESE
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY. FOR THIS
REASON WE SUPPORT THIS MEASURE
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
VERY MCH VERSION IS A WHAT'S
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY MATT A MODERATOR.
THAT'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. IN A TIME OF THE- THERE
IS NO ELSE. AT A MODERATOR
COMPLETELY TO A LAST CALL LAST
CALL FOR SUPPORT SB THIRTEEN
FORTY NINE. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SUPPORT SB ONE THREE
FOUR NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. THAT'S ONE ZERO FOUR
SUPPORT OF SB ONE THREE FOUR
NINE. THANK YOU MADAM MODERATOR
WILL HANG OUT HERE FOR JUST A
BIT TO BE TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE THAT'S GOING TO BE
COMING UP IN THE QUEUE WE
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK HERE TODAY.
MADAME MODERATOR TO HAVE ANYONE
IN THE QUEUE. AT THIS TIME WE
DO NOT MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU SO MUCH BETTER MODERATOR
LADIES IN GENERAL COMMITTEE
WE'RE NOT GONNA BE GOING TO IN
PERSON TESTIMONY HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE ANYONE
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
PLEASE DON'T RUSSIA MIKE.
HEARING SEEN NO ONE WE ARE NOW
GOING TO BE MOVING TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. NO ONE IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. IT'S A SAD ROOM
WE'RE NOT GONNA BE COMING BACK
HERE TO COMMITTEE WE'RE GONNA
BE CHECKING IN WITH THOSE WHO
MAY BE OPPOSED STAYS IN GENERAL
WE'RE NOT GONNA BE MOVING TO
OUR OPPOSITION ARE OPPOSITION
TO SB THIRTEEN FORTY NINE WE'RE
GONNA ASK THE MODERATOR TO
PLEASE QUEUE UP AND MAKE THE
ANNOUNCEMENT WE'RE LOOKING FOR
AN OUNCE WE'RE LOOKING FOR
THOSE WHO ARE OPPOSED TO SB
THIRTEEN FORTY NINE. BETTER
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE MAKE
THE ANNOUNCEMENT. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB THIRTEEN FORTY NINE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THIRTEEN FORTY
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE THAN
THEIR OWN NOW. THANK YOU SO
MUCH AS A MODERATOR CUES FOLKS
UP IN OPPOSITION WE'RE GONNA
REMIND FOLKS WOULD LOVE TO HEAR
FROM YOU. 844-291-6364 IS A
TOLL FREE NUMBER TO CALL AND
TALK TO THE COMMITTEE. YOU CAN
DIAL THAT CODE IS WELL SEVEN
EIGHT THREE SIX SEVEN FOUR FIVE
YOUR TOLL FREE NUMBERS
CURRENTLY ON YOUR SCREEN AGAIN
WE LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING FROM
YOU. IN OPPOSITION OF SB
THIRTEEN FORTY NINE WE'RE GOING
TO GO TO THE MODERATOR TO SEE
IF WE HAVE ANYONE IN THE QUEUE
A META MODERATOR. THANK YOU
MISTER. THREE THE LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD MORNING
THANK YOU MISTER THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN- THIS IS DAVID
SHOWN BROWN PRESIDENT OF
TRANSPORTATION SOLUTIONS
DEFENSE AND EDUCATION OF FUND-
SB THIRTEEN FORTY NINE IS BASED
ON A FRAUDULENT PREMISE. THAT
IT IS POSSIBLE TO HAVE A CAP ON
SALES TAXES WHILE EXEMPTING ALL
KINDS OF TAXES FROM THAT CAP IT
IS FUNDAMENTALLY DISHONEST THE
AUTHOR SHOULD BE ASHAMED OF
THEMSELVES. SECOND THIS IS.
THANK YOU IN LINE NUMBER TWENTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD BEFORE WE GO TO LINE
TWENTY MINIMUM WRITER I BELIEVE
WE MAY HAVE LOST ITS CHARM
BURNED IT WAS HE EXTENDED THE
HANG UP OF MATTER MODERATOR I
JUST NOT SURE IF HE WAS DONE
WITH HIS TESTIMONY BRING THEM
BACK. OKAY. MY NUMBER TWENTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN I
APPRECIATE THAT MISTER CHAIR- A
STATEWIDE FISCAL CRISIS NEEDS
TO BE ADDRESSED
COMPREHENSIVELY. AT THE STATE
LEVEL COUNTY BY COUNTY. ACTIONS
ARE THE WRONG WAY TO ADDRESS
THE PANDEMIC. FINALLY THERE'S
NO LEGITIMATE BASIS FOR
CLAIMINGTHAT THERE IS ANYTHING
UNIQUE ABOUT THE FISCAL
CONDITION OF CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY. THERE'S BEEN NO
WILDFIRES NOTES AND NOMINEES NO
EARTHQUAKES OR ANYTHING ELSE
THE ONLY THING THAT SETS THE
COUNTY APART. IS THAT IT'S
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY HAS
TWICE FAILED TO GATHER ENOUGH
COMMUNITY SUPPORT. TO PASS A
DOUBLING OF ITS SALES TAX THAT
THIS NOT JUSTIFY DESTROYING THE
STATEWIDE SALES TAX CAP. IN
ADDITION WE HAVE A COMMENT
LETTER IN YOUR PACKET THANK YOU
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT
MISTER CHAIR. MISTER SHERMAN
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE DO HAVE A
COPY OF THAT LETTER AND WE WERE
HAPPY TO PROVIDE THAT THE
COMMITTEE IS A WELL AND WE'RE
NOT GONNA BE GOING TO OUR NEXT
CALLER GAME SHERMAN THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COMMENTS NEXT CALLER
PLEASE MADAM MODERATOR. THANK
YOU LINE ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD
MORNING. THAT'S MY NUMBER
ELEVEN. GOOD MORNING NINE
ELEVEN WE'RE GONNA DO A LAST
CALL FOR LINE ELEVEN GOOD
MORNING. GOOD MORNING CAN YOU
HEAR ME YEAH YOU GOOD MORNING
YOUR LIFE AND COMMITTEE IF YOU
CAN PLEASE GIVE US YOUR FIRST
AND LAST NAME IN YOUR
ORGANIZATION YOUR NOW LIVE IN
COMMITTEE. GOOD MORNING. NINE
ELEVEN GOOD MORNING MA'AM. ALL
RIGHT NOT A MODERATOR WE'RE
GONNA BE GOING TO OUR NEXT
CALLER NEXT CALLER META
MODERATOR. THANK YOU LINE
NUMBER SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE HOLD GOOD MORNING.
YEAH MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS-
GOOD MORNING DAVID WOLF WITH-
WALRUS CONSULTING INCORPORATED
AGAIN ON BEHALF OF THE HARRY.
SIR SHE ASIAN IN OPPOSITION
MEMBERS OBVIOUSLY THE BILLS ON
RECONSIDERATION AND I KNOW
THERE ARE OTHER PEOPLE- IN THE
QUEUE WAITING TO TESTIFY SO I'M
GONNA BE BRIEFED- THE POINT YOU
MADE THAT THERE ARE 70% OF THE
NATION'S ECONOMIC OUTPUT THAT
IS BASED ON CONSUMER SPENDING
AND I. REALLY DO YOU THINK WE
SHOULD BE MINDFUL- THE
LEGISLATURE OPERATING YOU CAN
MORE TAXES WHICH IS WHAT WERE-
ATTEMPTING TO DO HERE TODAY
WITH SB THIRTEEN FORTY NINE-
THERE'S THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
NOTES ONLY 60% OF LOCAL SALES.
TAXES WERE APPROVED IN THE
MARCH ELECTION AND IF YOU
SEPARATE YOU THIRDS VOTE SALES
TAXES LOCALLY FROM THAT AT A
PERCENTAGE DROPS YOU EVAN
PERCENT- WHEN YOU COMBINE THAT
WITH THE FAILURE OF THE PROP
THIRTEEN SCHOOL BOND BACK IN
MARCH- I THINK. ARE RIGHTLY
CAUTIOUS ESPECIALLY AGAIN IN
THE MIDDLE OF NINETEEN AND I
LIKE ABOUT APPROVING EVEN MORE
TAXES AND DAD- AND YOU KNOW I
THINK AGAIN THAT JUST SERVES AS
A CAUTIONARY NOTE- WE LOOK
AHEAD. TO LIKE THAT WELL IT'S
ABOUT. NUMBER THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH RESERVE FROM HERE
ON OUT AND OF COMMITTEE WE'RE
GONNA BE A THE YOU'RE GONNA BE
TESTS OF IN OP TO LIST YOUR AND
LAST NAME ALONG WITH YOUR
ORGANIZATION IN YOUR POSITION
ON THE BILL WE'RE GONNA TAKE
THOSE TWO INDIVIDUALS AS OUR
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT NOT A
MODERATOR LET'S GO BACK TO THE
PHONE LINES WERE LOOKING FOR
THOSE TURN OPPOSITION- THE
FLOOR IS YOURS AND A MODERATOR.
MY NUMBER TWENTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING. HELLO THIS IS. A GOOD
MORNING. AND THANKS FOR
CONDUCTING THE MEETING AND THE
HEARING TESTIMONY MY NAME'S
MICHAEL RATHER. I AM A RETIRED
CITIZENS OF CONTRA COSTA COUNTY
AND A CO FOUNDER OF THE
ALLIANCE OF CONTRA COSTA
TAXPAYERS. AND I HAD. THAT
PREPARED TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
CURRENTLY NOT GOING TO ALLOW
ANY FURTHER THE EXTENT OF
TESTIMONY. SO I'M HERE IN
OPPOSITION YOU DO HAVE A LETTER
FROM OUR ORGANIZATION. THAT
HOPEFULLY IS PART OF THE PACKET
OR IT. MR RATHER WE REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY HERE
TODAY THANK YOU FOR JOINING US
AND THANKS FOR GETTING ON THE
LINE TODAY MISTER AT A FROM
THE- ALLIANCE FOR CONTRA COSTA.
TAXPAYERS WERE VERY GRATEFUL
SIR IN APPRECIATE YOU JOINING
US TODAY. WE'RE NOT GONNA BE
GOING TO OUR NEXT CALLER MADAME
MODERATOR. THANK YOU LINE
NUMBER TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD
MORNING. GOOD MORNING LINE
TWENTY FOUR LINE TWENTY FOUR
YOU ARE LIVE IN COMMITTEE GOOD
MORNING. NOT A MODERATOR LET'S
GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THAT
WAS THE LAST PERSON THAT A
MODERATOR CAN WE PLEASE DO A
LAST CALL LAST CALL FOR THOSE
WHO WERE IN OPPOSITION OF SB
THIRTEEN FORTY NINE MADAME
MODERATOR. THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION SB THIRTEEN FORTY
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE THAN
THEIR OWN NOW. IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THIRTEEN FORTY
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE DIDN'T
THEIR OWN NOW. THANK YOU WE'RE
GONNA TAKE A QUICK PIES WERE
GONNA ALLOW THE MODERATOR TO BE
ABLE TO QUEUE UP ANYONE ELSE
THIS IS OUR LAST CALL OUR LAST
CALL FOR THOSE WHO WERE IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THIRTEEN FORTY
NINE. GIVE US A QUICK MOMENT.
THANK YOU AND MISTER CHAIRMAN
WE DO HAVE LINE NUMBER TWENTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD GOOD MORNING. BOTH
MOMENTARILY BEFORE I WANTED TO
BE SURE BECAUSE I DIDN'T HEAR
AFFIRMATION THAT YOU DID
RECEIVE OUR LETTER FOR
ATTENTION OF THE COMMITTEE. I'M
SORRY IS THIS MR AROUND AGAIN.
IT IS THANK YOU ARE LETTER I
DIDN'T HEAR AFFIRMATION. I
BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE RECEIVED
YOUR LETTER. DOUBLE CHECK THE
FILE BUT IF OKAY GOLD BULL FIND
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER OUT OF THAT WAS OUR
CHIEF CONSULTANT CONGER NAIL
THAT SECOND VOICE IN WILL
CONFIRM- MISTER RATHER YOU'LL
HEAR FROM MY SITE SOON THAT WE-
CAN GET IN TOUCH WITH YOU LATER
TODAY AND GIVE YOU A VERBAL
CONFIRMATION ON THE PHONE SIR.
YES THE EMAIL ADDRESS IS AT THE
TOP OF THAT LETTER. OKAY MISTER
RIGHT I THANK YOU SO MUCH AND I
APPRECIATE YOU CALLING BACK IN
TO BE ABLE TO ASK FOR THAT
CONFIRMATION YOU'LL HEAR FROM.
MR GRINNELL LEADER TODAY MISTER
RIGHT I THINK YOU FOR YOUR
PHONE CALL IN. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY TODAY SIR. ALL
RIGHT. IN AT THE TIME OF THE
GERMAN THERE IS NO ONE ELSE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH BETTER
MODERATOR APPRECIATE YOUR WORK
HERE TODAY LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
COMMITTEE WE ARE NOW GOING TO
BE ASKING FOR OPPOSITION HERE
IN ROOM. FORTY TWO OH THREE.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION ROOM FORTY
TWO OR THREE WE ARE HEARING AND
SEEING NO ONE WE'RE NOT GOING
TO GO TO ROOM. TWENTY FORTY
ROOM TWENTY FORTY HERE AND SEEN
NO ONE. RIGHT NOW TO BE
BRINGING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
BUT I DO WAY TO SEE IF WE HAVE
A MOTION ON THE BILL- AND WE
HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR HER
TITLE. THAT MOTION IS TO PASS
TO THE FLOOR WITH ACCURACY IF-
WORD IS GOING TO GO STRAIGHT TO
THE VOTE SINCE IT'S UNDER
RECONSIDERATION. SO CORRECT AND
MR CANAL WERE ARE WE TAKING
TESTIMONY. IN THE QUESTIONS
REMEMBER CENTER PLEASE GO TO
MISTER VICE CHAIR. SORRY ABOUT
THAT MISTER VICE. NO NO THAT'S-
FINE I. OUR REPEAT ALL OF WHAT
I SAID. TWO WEEKS AGO MISTER
CHAIR JUST THAT THE- SB SIX ONE
EIGHT BY. SOMEONE STONE. WAS A
BILL THAT I LAID OFF OF AND IT
WENT TO THE GOVERNOR'S DESK AND
HE VETOED IT SO I'M JUST
CURIOUS WHY WOULD THIS BE ANY
DIFFERENT- SINCE THE GOVERNOR'S
VETO TO SIMILAR BILL. AND OUT
WITH THAT. I WOULD HOPE THE
GOVERNOR WOULD KIND OF HAVE A
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE SINCE
HE'S- KEPT THE ECONOMY LOCKED
DOWN FOR TWO MONTHS. ALL CITIES
AND COUNTIES. SUFFERING
FINANCIAL. DEVASTATION IF I
COULD FIND A OFA GOOD
ADJECTIVE- BUT I ONE OF THE
CALLERS MENTION MAYBE IT WAS
TIME TO RE LOOK AT EVERYTHING
AS OPPOSED TO JUST ONE COUNTY
SO I STILL REMAIN OPPOSED THANK
YOU MISTER. THANK YOU SO MUCH
RESERVE PRESSURE WERE VERY
GRATEFUL I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
TO NOTE THAT THIS DOES NOT
RAISE THE TAXES IT PROVIDES
THE- ABILITY FOR VOTERS TO
RAISE THE TAXES ARE LOCALLY BUT
I'D LIKE TO BE A TO SEE IF
SENATOR BELL CENTRE BELL DO YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS
REMOTELY. HEARING JEAN. I'M
SURE OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH
CENTER BALLOTS COULD YOU SEE
SIR. APPRECIATE THAT IS THERE
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONVERSATION.
HEARING SEEN NINE LAYS IN GENOM
AND WE DO HAVE A MOTION A
MOTION. BY SENATOR HURTADO
THAT'S ON THE FLIGHT WHICH IS
DUE PASSED TO THE FLOOR. MR NOW
CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR MCGUIRE HI. THERE ARE A
SENATOR MORLOCK OF MORE LOCK NO
SENATOR HERTZBERG. HI HERTZBERG
FIVE SENATOR HURTADO HI RICARDO
HI SENATOR NIELSEN NO. NIELSEN
NO SENATOR WINNER. WIENER FIVE
IF IT'S IN GERMAN THAT IS A
FOUR TO VOTE FOR TO VOTE THAT
BILL IS OUT WE'RE CLOSING THE
ROLE- ONE EIGHT TAKE A MOMENT
THIS IS GONNA BE MOST LIKELY
OUR LAST BILL HEARING OUR LAST
BILL HEARING- INTO MOST LIKELY
JULY. I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
TO THE VICE CHAIR FOR HIS
PARTNERSHIP THE VICE CHAIR AND
I'VE HAD SEVERAL CONVERSATIONS
IS WE MOVED INTO THESE BILL
HEARINGS- AND HE HAS BEEN
NOTHINGBUT A STATESMAN IN ALL
THIS AND I JUST WANT TO SAY HOW
GRATEFUL WE ARE TO THE VICE
CHAIR FOR YOU PARTNERSHIP SIR-
AND IT IS ALWAYS A PLEASURE TO
WORK WITH YOU BUT ESPECIALLY IN
TIMES OF CHALLENGE SO THANK YOU
MISTER VICE CHAIR AND ALL. I
TURN IT OVER TO YOU TO MAKE ANY
CLOSING COMMENTS YOU'D LIKE TO
BE A TO MAKE. I'M SORRY MISTER
CHAIR THE DISSIDENTS SO
ABBREVIATED YOU ARE AN HONOR TO
WORK WITH THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU MISTER
CRUSHER WE TRULY- WORKING
THROUGH THESE BILLS- WE COULD
NOT HAVE DONE IT WITHOUT
MORLOCK SO WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL.
I ALSO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE.
MISTER NOW MISTER NOW IT'S HAD
A LOT ON HIS PLATE. ALONG
TOGETHER AND FIGHT TEAM IN
MICHIGAN NOW IT'S BEEN CARRYING
THE LOAD HERE. ONWEARING
SEVERAL HATS. INTO CALLING YOU
OR JUST A PLEASURE TO WORK WITH
AND JUST WANTED KNOWLEDGE A
HERE TODAY. THANK YOU SO MUCH A
TO MAKE ALINA TO LDC FOR ALL
THE WORK. AND KEEP IT IS MOVING
TO THE SERGEANTS OF COURSE WERE
VERY GRATEFUL ON OF COURSE TO
THE CAUCUS. WHO IS HERE EACH
AND EVERY HEARING. AIDS IN
GENERAL AND THIS WILL BE OUR
FINAL- MOST LIKELY OUR FINAL
BILL HEARING FOR SENATE BILLS-
WILL LET YOU KNOW IF ANYTHING
CHANGES. WE ARE NOW ADJOURNED.